Let's now talk about various problems that
resulted from IPv4 and the growth of the
internet routing tables, and two different solutions
to internet routing table growth: network address translation,
or NAT, and IPv6. So the main problem that we are seeing is that IPv4
addresses have only 32 bits, which means that there are, can only be a total of
2 to the 32 unique IP addresses. Not only that, as we've seen, IP
addresses are allocated in blocks, and fragmentation
of this space can mean that IPv4 addresses
can be quickly exhausted. In fact, we've
already seen the last slash eight from IPv4
address space allocated to the registries. So
we're well on our way towards running out
of IPv4 addresses. In some sense, you can say that we've
essentially already run out. In this lesson, we're going to look at
two solutions: network address translation, or NAT, and IPv6, whose main
feature is 128 bit addresses. Let's first take a look at NAT.